[Music]  pollution still affects many Europeans  that's why you programs are supporting  cleaner solutions including replacing  old smoke creating boilers in one polish  region Scotia snow and ethical stay  docked at sea pavilion needed a new bill  especially ocean patients in their pets  if a dictionary yes butter Georgia for  protection under the Green Deal we  committed to become a climate neutral  continent by 2050 however for some  regions it will be more difficult than  for others because they are heavily  reliant on fossil fuels this is why  during the transition the EU will  provide specific support to ensure that  no region and no person is left behind  the just transition mechanism will  mobilize 100 billion euros to support  region's most hit by the climate  transition this will fund the rescaling  of people cleaner transport and energy  efficient housing  [Music]